[Music]
um speaking more about the switch I
don't know Pete you put something up
recently that was like Wii U exclusive
we want to see it was a very thoughtful
and well researched gallery you
interviewed Miyamoto for it right
imagine a simple gallery cuz it was like
okay there are a lot of Wii U games that
are great that maybe people missed and
why not have him on swish because Mario
Kart 8 is a really good example of a
game that was even super popular when it
came out and yet is more popular now
which is great to see for a great game
uh yeah so I just like ran down you know
ten exclusives to make it sound like a
gallery and a gallery it was and here we
aren't talking about it what we you
games do you want on social angle mm
Bayonetta 2 okay because I never played
banned a tattoo and I have an excuse now
I know what I wasn't really too much
into the Wii U unfortunately but but
what about the idea of like port begging
right or like or like just saying like
well now there's a platform we like so
we should get these games over here
because I'm of the mind where it's like
I would personally like to play these
but do I want devs taking up time that
could be spent on new games report this
stuff that's yeah that's kind of a
that's like winwaker again then yeah
well yeah I know I was gonna say I will
play Wind Waker once again if they
released it in HD on the switch yeah I I
mean going back to what you said Mike
though it's like I didn't how do we you
all right still have a Wii U I didn't
play it that often because it just
wasn't a great system and so there's
games that I want to play that just
didn't feel right and so like Tokyo
Mirage sessions is a game that I think I
would actually finally get into on
switch because I would have more time
and this is winwaker which is so much
spleen okay explain Tokyo Mirage
sessions to me because I saw gameplay
last year when it two years ago when it
really two years ago so it is it um yeah
I get we can help each other that's
sound like Rob's favorite game let's
tag-team this so it's it's an RPG set in
Tokyo set in Tokyo um it's more talking
to Madison Ellie about this cuz talking
about game
to play after persona 5 and he was like
yeah it's like in a similar vein but
just way happier um his teens aren't
really as far as I understand dealing
with a lot of angst and turmoil and
they're not crying they're not unhappy -
Tokyo Mirage sessions is happier than
persona yeah yeah yeah yes why is that
such a hearty laugh do you see what they
were just doing every fight like in
those big arenas is like a pop concert I
mean it revolves around entertainment it
revolves it's yeah it's it's a definite
light-hearted game especially compared
to persona 5 yeah yeah
Felipe I'd are on twitch apology from
bitching her name says all the special
package with winwaker Twilight Princess
and Skyward Sword skully jean Kollection
yeah that'd be awesome
I'd be good so I've never played Skyward
Sword but I think I would actually play
it if it were on sesh he there's mixed
Justin hey while were just replaying it
recently before breath of the wild came
out I liked Skyward Sword the first time
I played it and then I played it more
and I I know the running joke is to like
not like Navi because she annoys you in
Ocarina but fee she tells you how to
complete puzzles like straight up when
you walk into a room and you start you
know you see a new room in a dungeon and
Zelda you're first you're just trying to
gain some sort of spatial awareness and
figuring out what's going on in the room
she'll stop you before you can even do
that and say oh it looks like those
electric balls will open this door if
you can get it across that why are you
telling this I could figure it out an
idiot
I love the battles outside that little
area that we link was going around like
that little circular like walkway down
there there are some really cool moments
in this game but but by and large it's
not that special I I just feel like a
bad Zelda fan for not having played it
um like I want to play it for my own
sense of completion and I think the
reason I just want like the reason
switch is more appealing to me than any
of the previous platforms for some of
these games that aren't immediately
attractive to me because I hate the art
style actually of this game a lot is
just the switch being portable and me
being nearsighted I can actually bring
things closer to me and I don't know why
but that's a big draw for me and I know
that's
as hell but it actually has improved my
experience like was Zelda I only play at
handheld for example so I think with
some of these games that I missed on Wii
you were before that I would really
enjoy on switch this is bringing back
good memories yeah you've got like the
worst opening in a Zelda game really
hearing it is even you talk about V
spelling things out for you this game
tutorial eyes is like have you ever
played a video game before we're going
to teach you what it means to move using
a controller and my everything is just
so it's like 2 hours of tutorials before
you can really get into the game like
proper like the adventure
I like the flying with the loft wings
yeah you still talk about Skyward Sword
right yeah yeah she doesn't say there's
some bad openings in Zelda in general I
was yeah I was gonna say like worse than
the super slow Twilight Princess
sequence worse yeah yeah yeah cuz
Twilight Princess isn't as much I mean
it tutorial eise's things but most of
that is just like setting up the really
somber melancholic tone of the game yes
which I afterwards I'll I princess
really dark Skyward Sword feels like my
first zelda adventure that kind of thing
yeah but in terms of other Wii U games
do you have any utility I was gonna say
thinking about the switch and maybe how
like how Mario Kart was so cool and
honestly like getting into a game on my
couch playing right card online is like
super quick and I'd be excited to see
another multiplayer title
maybe it's and I'm thinking about how
does anyone play like jack box on yeah I
played it yet on this which no not on
switch but I know jack but um I'm just
thinking about how that game like what's
the game in that the draw 'full no it's
one where you're guessing people guess
who's who was it Fitbit oh no oh not fit
it's another one I I wish I remembered
Oh an unknown work not guess is a guess
peonage no that's not good either retry
yes the right answer like the most
popular answer in a chat we'll get to it
yeah you're trying to you trying to say
it's what like raise your hand if you uh
ever like go to the doctor last month
and area nage isn't it
the spy-1 gonna get a guess who sure
anyways my point being
I would like to see like a Mario Party
hit that would maybe incorporate that
kind of idea of like hide your screen or
some like that like and maybe like I'm
at a private type of like game mode or
something like that I don't know that
there's something to be said about like
in the office here like people who do
happen to have like other friends with
switches like that mobile aspect people
it was a bad friend with switches
continued that could rules me out I
think that'd be cool I like to see more
multiplayer titles making its way um you
could mention it's kind of I think you
were saying it's a stretch because it's
coming out
there's the sequel coming out but what
is the open-world when you're on that
the Giants fakin it thank you Xenoblade
crossing over do you think you know
faking it was the jack box game
Xenoblade is the game you're talking of
like the moniker an X across cross
depending on your region X or cross or X
cross you know Japan its cross yeah I
believe like Pro no-necks chrono X total
cross current yeah [ __ ] kpop do so
Xenoblade Chronicles you would like that
on the Wii U yeah I like that game a lot
and I just watch people miss it I I hate
this guy so much well I can see why oh
my god like his scar I hate him so so
much this game has horrible voice acting
which is like one of its worst that
sucks but like as for an open-world like
RPG it's really really good and I really
like the combat it's very it's a good
sort of progression from the original
Xenoblade Chronicles on the Wii what
happens like 5060 hours into this game
you're setting this huge world with
things that seem way too big but didn't
you get in mechs yeah it happens like so
late in the game yeah the whole game and
your whole perspective on the world
changes and suddenly these monsters that
are towering above you are like more
your size and it's just like a it's such
a cool late-game
expansion to what you've been doing at
the song pool I remember you reviewing
that game and you were pretty torn but
they're not torn but I remember you like
saying you're trying to explain here
like yet later on it becomes this whole
different game almost yeah yeah yeah and
I kind of wish it it got to that point
earlier I don't know didn't you guys
play Xenogears musician RPG so you get
mechs in now
came similarly you don't get them until
kind of far in but it's not as far I
feel like they were trying to go for a
similar thing here anyway yeah
so they're coming out was you know like
chronicles to the original Xenoblade
Chronicles did not involve mechs so I
don't expect to see those in Xenoblade
Chronicles 2 so you know in that sense
if there are no mechs in the new one
having this there might be a nice
complement to the Xenoblade verse switch
um philanthropy on youtube was just
saying if you're talking about this game
you thought that soundtrack that's been
Janka right yeah okay that's why I
thought but he'd been genka he does a
lot of our behind the scenes stuff for
GameSpot publishing and whatnot he was
saying yeah talk about the soundtrack
do you remember the soundtrack did stand
out no it doesn't Bend I'm sorry I let
you down
was it a Gaston or even pseudo joint
yeah ah
figure-eight yeah I feel like we have to
mention smash yeah this for sure I mean
that's very obvious yeah oh that has to
happen mm-hmm um I mean splatoon too is
coming out but you were talking uy like
another kind of multiplayer thing but
for sure like just playing Mario Kart
online yeah party stuff party stuff not
one to switch what I was poorly trying
to say was like just something you know
they have such a really unique device
like I could just see people thinking
outside the box maybe like a jack box
way that was horrible so like I can go
right yeah you can touch ways of just
incorporating that oh my god Wow um I
really she know what you're like red now
anyway I think Super Mario maker
is is almost yeah oh no for sure
absolutely
would that work as well without the
stylus you've got nature's stylus scale
the one what god just smile us away from
Sultan but it's a lie the nature's I
understand why you did that but the way
I thought you're flipping me is the way
you angled your hand was a little um
yeah you do have nature's stylus um I
just want to know yeah I mean this
conversations just wanted yeah I just
want all these new games to come out
like we talked about this on the lobby a
few
to go like what franchises we want to
actually see come back not games ported
and just Metro is the obvious one a new
smash would be great who knows when that
would happen do we need a new fish yeah
why what did well see one what like see
why we didn't need smash on the Wii U a
new Mario Kart well no so we're not
bought mmm what is that argument okay I
would like to say that it would be a
poor of smash on Wii U because they take
soccer I like at least six years for
each smash so it's not any new but I
think he's I think he realizes that and
is still arguing for a new I will argue
anything if I feel like I would win the
argument I don't need backup from I
don't need to back on my points I need
to justify myself to you and your smelly
stylist no not you are you oh don't
worry my argument I am it was weird uh
any other so we just say they want a
system shock Don Mattrick on YouTube oh
no it's just some shock so we're gonna
come to switch F to Euro would be dank I
love a zero that's how Captain Falcon
was diet dang alright I think we talked
enough about we you uh
you